happy Monday dude dude dude are you what
nice I got you biking now no I got oh so
annoying dude I'm shooting this movie I
get they left my makeup line hey dude
listen listen listen do you mean there
take this off with Leslie can I take it
off with a scented you had a small part
in the movie I did as well that's more
than you that's what's so frustrating
when they toilet what nope guys come on
Bryan's been to us forever what - you
have you're a lot yeah you did not I
promise I did you had a lot of lines
yeah sorry man I told my sobriety news
for everything cool guy gave you the
role I can handle that I said I go I
went I should probably be there but go
ahead and give it to him it's an I hate
it and I went I went I could have been
like no and I went got to knowing I gave
you that role when I when they went dude
you nailed this and you have more length
than calment alright man you gotta bring
accounting back for another day in gym a
few more long I don't want to do movies
okay cuz I was offering to Pierre part
in that movie I said no because I was
too busy it's not what I heard
he's have a [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
we've been doing dude where were you at
I was an Indianapolis Brenden
Minneapolis I hung out with your boy
Matt Mitrione I learned from that
forever how's he hey he's great his
friend haystack was a trying man he
knows haystack he rolls with a group
called the two-ton Club the two-ton Club
fit Alec yeah they're all ex-football
players they're just big guys love their
alcohol you're in a wall of flesh you
would have been at home cuz you're very
big but for me I would not been at home
I don't like dying I don't enjoy being
around that you don't know like you all
enjoyed [ __ ] at the end of the night
but yeah I got [ __ ] yes I'm very
aware you did the best was Matt who's
big man on campus there we loved it
because we're always we roll in the back
and the guys looking at Matt as they
come to your show yeah they go now again
and then the guy sees me way in the back
goes oh yeah you guys go ahead and I
just went I went
sorry Matt and just watch your show and
know at the club at the bar we went to
kill Royce afterwards Oh which is near
the club yeah yeah right now the club it
was fun man Matt's doing great Lizzie
he's doing he has a fight coming up
I don't know I think his did he beat did
he beat a kharitonov that was his last
fight here coming the boss that coming
all right accident that's really Malik's
great he looks great I always do he lost
the Bader for the world title right oh
no now he lost Bader that y8 it so he
fought Bader in the tournament to get to
the World title Bader beat him and then
that's how bad it's gonna sound like a
really dumb question but I didn't know
beta was big enough to fight Matt Peters
a big boy yeah he's just small for a
heavyweight but he's just more technical
than those guys yeah I did not see that
fight yeah the Matt's doing the Dow yeah
it's right Keerthana we kicked around
the nuts on accident yeah he's doing
good though huh yeah heard from you know
what I promise it like liked Oracle eyes
guys I lost my phone
yeah or broke had to get a new one and I
upload my cloud but all the contacts and
transfer so I don't know sit for sit for
months now well people text me I have no
idea who it is I'm gonna happen to me I
lost I don't want to respond back to him
so I'm like on who is it I know I hate
that and then the worst sup like to say
something really nice like oh cool
sirens they hate to do this but who is
this I'm like come on man I know dude
just be cool tell me who it is I know I
know I got that horse so mad if you text
me sorry dude I didn't see it why did I
have no idea who it's from
yeah I some guy was joking around with
me on Instagram my dirt dm's
he's funny and then then he just broke
into some racist [ __ ] started telling he
racist jokes and I go I go you know I
never block anybody knockers on you know
I never block anybody but I know [ __ ]
you and your race is [ __ ] you little
[ __ ] and just Jesus first time I owned
this do ya I've only bought two people
and you're out there with Allah's sake
on a both race you old to be having
conversations be funny and I was just
God would just be like ah you know how
first of all I don't even know I must
have okayed them in the first place it's
nice to me you know and on my whatever
that is when you look at your request
I'm so bad with this [ __ ] I I did a show
at flappers on Saturday night with Fahim
ass on in that written rap
or it came right yeah great show and so
for him and a son so for him from I
think he's Afghani and then Assange from
India and so there's been a constant
thing on my on my feet that that I
snipped on the red light I'm like the
streaming stuff yeah
which obviously I they they know I
didn't it was just something fun for
them to do yeah but whatever stream
snitch yeah and a lot of that I don't
see J was coming like there's no either
that's stupid to believe that he's a guy
don't know so then I was the picture for
him and son I was a K I heard the UFC
streams are down got the two best IT
guys in the business working on it they
just look [ __ ] Indian it's [ __ ] that's
so freakin goes do you think I'm gonna
get hey tango for sure that's so funny
I didn't read the caption that looked
really funny they could look more like
an eye to eye thing look at us or like
in the with green room I've got my IT
guys in the green room working on those
illegal you know see streams best in the
biz so hopefully we get them right back
to us [ __ ] hilarious and then I put
cuz Jay Jay goes I went and I think the
best way to do is to kill it with humor
and Jay goes yeah but some people really
think you got the streams put down with
no way so I put PS there's no way people
are stupid enough to think of the power
to get stream shut down right yes pin is
ESPN is owned by Disney point your anger
at Mickey
they don't play that [ __ ] it was if it
was uh it was just a matter of time
pay-per-view number sucks of course ESPN
shut that [ __ ] down because they're like
why our numbers so bad and then illegal
streaming and yeah yeah this is a
perfect story watch the fights I side
watched him the next day cuz I was a
flap was doing our show while the fights
were I was that we had problems but even
with DSP net we have problems like my
girl couldn't get it she sick we tried
getting it then she was the night to
watch it on my phone she won't work on
the TV a bunch people had problems
I was just trying to figure it out and
Indianapolis that Hooters was right
across the street from the club so I
just ran across there and like I didn't
even say I wanted to say take pictures
afterwards but I just wanted to see
cowboy fight I'd rather have someone
take a hammer to my dick than watch a
fight at Hooters well you know what it
was empty was [ __ ] me and Matt and
friends went over there and nobody was
there we went right there and watched
the fights that that that was a what you
think what you think of the fights say
one well
Henry cejudo is I mean that guy's I'm
Marla Martin
Maurice was gonna was was gonna figure
him out amazing he's amazing and then
that Olympian that gold medalist that
he's been outclassed early on he's
getting how the [ __ ] he gonna do this
and then don't get me wrong I think it's
a matter of Instituto being a beast but
it's more of Marlin Mariah's just
weak-minded you need to yeah we start
taking these and getting punched well no
he stopped he just kind of stopped doing
what was so great was working you
stopped and then you think about
something you know he's having a issue
when coach Henry Hesco didn't he off see
he's quit in the gym there's something
going on there when Mark Henry goes come
on think about what your mom sacrificed
to get you here I'm like Jesus Christ I
Steve so they must see that that he's
broke before that's that's something you
wouldn't say so it's a good diet he's
got himself to that point right so
sometimes when the going gets rough
though everyone's super-talented when
the going gets rough like he [ __ ] -
who - up but pseudo wasn't going away
well they see you like sitting in a pot
but was sued I'm like what the [ __ ] is
he doing
you see mark area behind like this like
what did I didn't see like what are you
doing what are you doing yeah and then
so just get them into this brawl and
just kind of took crazy say say that
that that mindset for say who know that
that cold metal mine said I mean winning
a gold medal in the Olympics like in
wrestling like I can't think of anything
harder you know so he's been I think he
lived at the Olympic Training Center for
three years when he was 18
yeah and just that that training that
that hot that it's like the same thing
with Daniel Cormier that level of
training that there's no quit in him at
all and I think that at the end of the
day it's like you do see that in some of
these eyes it's like this guy's never
gonna quit I'm punching him as hard as I
can but it was where Marlon was melting
he also looks like Jeff Bezos on
steroids we're aware of this right he
has a good body
he looks identical - janaki white I
don't want you to get they looked at
identical when he was like that's all I
could see I'm not gonna give you that
use me they look i dead - Clara let me
see it
Bezos done TRT a [ __ ] Hardy he's
right out of his mind by the way this
kid yeah
and Mitchell who gstreamer them said
that he was that way when he was broke
it's not it's not like he's got that's
I'm sorry what are you saying that's
natural no Mitchell used to train with
him when he's broke
Mitrione said he was I said is that that
looks like his body looks enhanced Oh
Matt said I don't wanna I'm not I'm
really not I really respect him I'm not
saying this but Mitchell said that
dude's body was just like that when he
had no money Suze definitely not on
anything he's just a [ __ ] rocked out
[ __ ] interesting take there yeah
yeah good fights though yeah I bought
sow boy so let me ask you this uh
let me ask you talk about that she
should say who note would you would you
tell CEO to go challenge Holloway and
what do you think happens uh no this to
me this to me good guys that 135 yes
here's to way more work at 135 for a job
245 yeah do UFC wouldn't entertain that
it wouldn't no no there's too many
fights at 35 for way too many he called
all the guys that there's there's great
fight for him at 35 like who at 35
I mean stir well sterling just won he'd
be a beast form Dominick Cruz garb rant
like this Dominick Cruz stealth yeah
he's almost fight you just came off that
injury though Wow but Cruz is a big name
sterling would be fun sterling deserves
that he had a big win and then you know
Cody Cody garbage needs to win one he's
right back there dude there's way more
fight that 3545 I mean also he's not
getting paid like okay go be triple
champion new season hmm small guys don't
get paid he got in the mic you and I
want to get paid heavyweight money it's
never happy
which is a bummer right it's never had
yeah so good so good missile was mighty
mouth forever forever was my mess do you
don't get paid the small guys just don't
get paid I I'm in trouble I'm intrigued
by the idea then fighting max Holloway
was way bigger away it's it's silly to
talk about it's never gonna happen cause
he has so much work to do at 35
does he like I mean he beat he beat
arguably the best 35 ever TJ Dillashaw
but he beat him at 25 doesn't count does
that that's 30 okay so he's had one
fight at 35 okay so you can jump to 45
you do work at 35 it's got a fight card
is even a conversation we really I think
Bieber and [ __ ] Tom Cruise have a
better chance like really you seem like
it'll jump to 45 hmm 45 stat it is stack
you think you have season go okay so you
hold the bell at flyweight which you
won't have to defend that you hold the
bell that bantamweight what you have to
fend that then go jump over it [ __ ]
feather for pure eyes on on you know for
pay-per-view numbers I think that would
be a big fight people would watch it you
think yes to see for the first time in
UFC history because Taylor would jump at
the opportunity could he win three belts
and three divisions that's almost
anything you do that and then go back to
40 think you do it I don't know why they
wouldn't dude it doesn't work well
that's not their business plan mm-hmm
cuz then then so he holds three belts so
you're holding up two entire divisions
yeah it doesn't make sense
I know it's like fun do you want to
protect you wanna protect it 45 it's
like a fun [ __ ] fanboy thing too tightly
to do that like when you say on the mic
going oh that's not it's just not it's
not it's fun to talk about that's not
happening right it's just you'd have to
hold up three divisions yeah yeah copy
gets paid but I just it's not bad at
that size they just don't pay you
it's a weird it's just because people
are just ultimately not interested in
small men right they're just name the
biggest superstar that the Mighty Mouse
was the biggest thing is never just a
big yeah they just don't bring in the
money like the big boys yep it's the
market value it's not hating of Sahu
dough yeah do you think he's the best
combat sports athlete of all time do i I
don't know how to answer that question I
mean I I think you have to know gold
medal gold medal and I first ever to own
a gold medal yeah an Olympics beats mags
my mouse arguably the pound-for-pound
right beats TJ Dillashaw you know say
really well very quick fight but
that doesn't matter he's definitely in
the conversation I mean you know he's
the worst haircut belongs to cowboy
he's Hari Krishna that's a heart Krishna
it's so I don't know what what has to he
is like I don't like he's loose in the
front three you know let's just do kitty
London look like Calvary let's go to
Paris hamster ish
of course it's hamster ish he looks like
a Hari Krishna like what are you doing
it's gonna I have a privy to talk about
who is all I did when he walked away
boy is that mullet don't touch the back
I want to grow it out I want to fluff
but it's like bluffing I like faded and
skinny and then but it's not it's a
squirrel tail he has a squirrel tail
he's like we're on man but [ __ ] Davy
Crockett it's pretty key look pretty
cool though I gotta be honest
lovelyz for these he's he's the most
decorated in men he's that we he's the
most decorated fighter in UFC history he
is the most decorated most wins uh most
I mean he's got look at did you see what
all the lists of what he's done it's
crazy
he's incredible it's just mission myths
in the shilada I'm missing the big
enchilada it's the only one that matters
I'm it yeah I was I was although now I
mean whose career would you rather have
Cowboys Cowboys why you didn't hear you
didn't you don't hear that well we got
tell me but I mean already I'm saying
Cowboys as far as like well yes he has
more wins than Derek or me would you
rather be Daniel Cormier who's a two
division champion world champion or
cowboy I think I'll not always either
either be cowboy I think he's the most
colorful he's the most popular in a lot
of ways and I think that he he's just I
don't know I think what he's done is
incredible even though yet you know
another beat you know my spot for most
knockdowns neo see history number two
knockdowns games he is mostly uh
bonuses right most bonuses second
performance overall he has a lot of
warts real any guilt yeah is it cannot
words yeah it was almost it was a bummer
that it did stop in the second was the
second round third round second round it
was a bummer but also
that was gonna get ugly for cowboy I was
glad they stopped it because I I just
don't want to see him get punched in the
face he doesn't he's just such a tough
[ __ ] that he'll stand there and but
Tony's got that weird the jabs and all
that stuff just what about that lady I
think told me that happen but cutter I
don't care that's been effective fight I
don't care it might have closed his eye
out though definitely did it you see the
replay no so that's why the fight gets
stopped so I know I know why the fight
got stopped so what they you know they
didn't hear sound so they replayed it so
if it would land in the high right
cowboy would have won via TKO right
but because landing the chin if that's
not the reason that I filled ups cuz he
blew that's the only reason that cuz the
punch okay punch was just uh you know
Tony means passion in the healing moment
should have way more self-control yeah I
don't didn't affect the fight yeah yeah
bad guy had nothing not that now he was
starting to get ugly for cowboy what
yeah yeah Tony's a night we're gonna say
I was gonna say that
I was glad they stopped it yeah me too I
really was I I think I see after I
watched that and after what Tony's been
through I think he's the best 155 around
the planet he's the only 55 verse which
hit that top level that gets better
after three rounds his cardio is it pace
is cardio as the rounds go on you'll see
first round he's kind of a slow starter
sack round starts to gain win third
round he's really flowing forth he's
[ __ ] good fifth it's caution to the
wind he's the only 55 who can do that
well the fighters are obviously khabib
and Tony but he was landing that jab he
just did something about that he was
he's just such a [ __ ] nightmare man
he's a nightmare he's he's so creative
so confident he's just how do you with
khabib if you have to put money on that
obviously if cubby grabs ahold of him
you know it was hands full man Tony off
his back is a nightmare
I would you honestly my prediction I
think Tony wins via TKO doctor stoppage
cuz from elbows I think he cuts khabib
up so bad that's not a fight oh I don't
think could be blast five rounds with I
think Tony is
cardio FC better stand up he's been in
the in the transitions and I think his
cardio is better and I just think he's
not gonna get submitted he's gonna make
khabib work a whole lot it's why that
fourth fifth round you see a tidal wave
of Tony if kabhi kabhi clinches Tony
goes down I think he's always gone I
told him you take you down yeah
people take that anybody yes but but if
if Tony can keep khabib obviously at a
distance and stop the takedown
that's not happy that's nice move so his
game is a pressure he's gonna go for
Tony so they're always gonna there it's
gonna be a grappling gonna get taken
down you know I can stay on the outside
yeah that's not not listen so if he if
it's if it's takedown if it's a takedown
game though Cubs gonna edge him out I
think Aaron disagree because khabib
lands was take down he's just position
guy and Tony so good off his back with
elbows he's I think he's gonna make
could be work a ton and then what we saw
in that i cuenta fight after the third
round khabib gets tired start shooting
far out and that's Tony first about they
I think him it could be work man
yeah and then in Tony's that nightmare
to hold down he's a nightmare his elbows
off his back his back he's good man I'm
I think Tony's the best 155 were on the
planet
you think he B's could be I do I didn't
believe that for a while but I don't
know man I think you beat them I just
wonder if I wonder if there's any way
you're still on your back as good as you
are with a guy like khabib you're still
at a disadvantage because you you it
could be at that point he's just physics
when I listen to me be Tony's gonna get
taken down pulling us back one round two
round three rounds by rounds four and
five just from the output of holding
Tony down is when it could be faith that
fourth and fifth round Tony gets better
so like in the Conor fight and the Beave
got tired remember sort of got sort of
tired and lost the round and can miss
shots in I'll quit the fight he got
tired
well if Tony can weather that storm he's
on the ground that's that's the big
question if he doesn't finish guess the
unless guy finished he just punches
for a long time they holds position yeah
well if could be if if Tony doesn't go
to his doesn't kind of try to grab a
role go out and get his legs caught the
way everybody else does and have that
backpack then and he can stay on his
back but I can kento knee if khabib on
top of you you know can Tony deal with
that kind of that kind of [ __ ] I
don't know I mean I know you're saying
oh you got Kevin Lee in a triangle choke
kill he's pretty [ __ ] good on top
that's right I'm really excited about it
then you got a Valentina Shevchenko my
girlfriend mmm she kill the girl Harris
oh great I feel so bad for Jessica
should she woke up she goes what I got
knocked out I think you have no idea she
was down for a while that's really bad
yeah you know what makes it worse if
chef shank is just like hmm-hmm just
like she's just she knocked down like
tiptoe about like village man I know she
like danced over her looks just branch
like almost stepped on was like John I
just stood Darius man what a what a and
this and then just guy comes to and just
shevchenko with her finance sister and
the killer [ __ ] coaches are just
staring at her oh my god get out of the
cage Wow my girl says her Spanish isn't
better than hers I don't her Spanish
she's amazed the trilingual she's
amazing she's amazing in general I love
her my girl my girl gosh Oh her Spanish
is better than 99% of Telemundo people
tell them no best by far in the UFC she
was named it name someone whose makes em
stance and you see cuz way better went
really just unbelievable
she was it's it's literally perfect
Spanish God why then where does she live
I think she lived in Brazil too so she
speaks perfect Portuguese as well yeah
and she when I place her room I go and
she can probably do math like at the
[ __ ] like that's the kind of person
she's so intense like god knows what
she's about she shoots guns but her
sister definitely likes Spanish go to
kill her Wikipedia what's going on there
I'm not trying to watch a documentary on
her
I just got a wisk upz for gosh sakes
none of us speak Spanish or we don't
know how good it is you know yeah so if
you play that chin roll I want to see it
actually the early life Shevchenko USSR
Soviet Taekwondo tie
oh she's I know she was Russian huh
thought she was polish serious bro yes
Wow I know man there's not that cuz why
is their sister so dark and fine you
know I'm saying
her sister looks straight Spanish geez
maybe she's our half-sister that's what
I'm thinking I'm like no not Brazil no
they do not look this they do no don't
look any same at all yeah yeah her
Spanish is money
what other fight was oh sure I speaks
English not I'm sorry not Portuguese
English Russian and Spanish you made
that up about her she did Oh from a
Kyrgyzstan e family um yeah I wonder
where the [ __ ] the Spanish comes from
she lived to somewhere for a while
were they spoke to you bro science in
this right remember this in interviews I
think it's Peru and she just picked it
up there well she's not got a 22 year
old opponent or any harmonica bullet I'm
her trainer feather off yeah she's
killing it what another fights run like
Tatiana did work she get the next title
shot I would imagine
sterling looked great Kelvin K dollars
[ __ ] kill the guy I didn't see that
fight bad knockout yeah those last three
man's to who dough Shevchenko
then obviously first time with the I
think a point Jimmy Revere lost again
that heavyweight fight not fun there was
a little fun moments I don't know um how
was Minneapolis in general I get a go
there Indianapolis but I see a hapless
do sometimes I thought you know I'd let
you told me Mindy an ambulance Indian
yeah and look I like the town and I love
the people you know the club the club
just needs it's a new club so that just
need to be a little bit more what is it
it's helium yeah but you don't know that
because there's no sign is it on a mall
yeah and they just gotta get better
they've got to get better advertise to
them not to be a dick but I walk down
the street and I get recognized every 10
feet you gotta do better but I'm just
saying but but it's true like up the no
but for real like I'm walking down the
street you gotta you gotta have at least
have an advertisement says when you're
walking by that I'm there that's all in
this so they got to do better they're
new they're a new operation but you know
I get a little mad about that stuff yeah
and but the day and age of like walked
ups man it's like comics now it's your
social media podcast this it's fine but
it still works listen all I'm trying to
say is that there are people there are
people that when you walk by a comedy
club and there's no sign you don't know
it's a comedy club tough and then you
got it you got it just show it who's
there that's all yeah it's really simple
as I don't know you do right sure yeah
and you do get you do get a lot of like
there are a lot of clubs that do get a
lot of walk-up business especially where
that Club is you'll see really yeah
opportunity yeah that's a great area to
talk to you there's a great area yeah
I'm mark somebody up was he cool yeah
mark mark gets it but I I know mark
really well and I like him very much and
I love his clubs so I I you know I had a
long talk with him about it he's cool
with it yeah yeah I get mad but he sent
me a very aggressive hell yeah yeah I
don't want to talk about I get heated up
we were in Vegas on Saturday dude yes we
are
when Vegas together yeah we weren't
gonna show in a hot second we've done
stand-up yeah I'm excited it'll be fun
very fun chin are you coming yeah Kelly
you got your Cathy coming I'm getting
our same hotel different hotels you are
the same same we're you stay engine I am
Jim
I'm Jim sciutto 13 say something weird
no I think I've seen em Jim we'll see
what happens when I get there what do
you mean someone DM me saying he can
hook me up with a rock God for a
discount shin to it oh I didn't so
that's a discounted room so Jim you gave
me credit card no no my guess is my
guess is fighting to keep my pay for you
guys to stay there we'll see about how
to talk to the Treasury you'll have to
her first yeah we've read paid forecasts
were you talking much yeah that's all
thank you okay
jul 19 2014 11
did we that's sushi remember that sushi
we ate and we both were like no I
remember no you don't let over there
really a rich guy with the girls if you
leave you're not getting the money sure
do sure do I'm are you an iron that was
so strange gaudy sweet gone awesome
these all these gals are there and we're
like it's like one old guy Brian bikes
me this thing goes hey this guy pay this
much money if you come banging at this
thing so with this old guy he's I was
doing a show for him you know this this
gaming thing and so Brian goes hey if
you come to this thing - they're gonna
pay for an appearance fee like fi I get
hanging with Brian seem easy money man
so I fly down for one night so we do the
game thing then we're all he's like
invite through into his room so it's
like so guy me Brian few other random
dudes and then a flock of young girls
and yeah I'm so awkward - so we're like
I actually knew one from LA cuz she's
friends with a friend
yeah buddy of ours so now
like and then one girl doesn't matter if
you leave you're not getting your money
well I felt so yeah remember you go I'm
a deep I don't there so sex traveling
and [ __ ] out of what's that night now I
know I I felt so guilty having all my
moms like this is wrong this is wrong I
can't believe I'm Katie well but you
know what it wasn't about the last time
we were together that's weird yeah I've
had a couple of those situations where
you get in there and you're with the
people that you don't know that well and
all these girls show up I an experience
like that in Mexico where the guy was a
Wall Street guy and we're just not
talking and all of a sudden like 10
girls walk in and you're like oh boy
this doesn't this this is bad like these
girls like hear you these guys don't
want to be here everybody here's an
older dude and it's just [ __ ] gross
like you're just like who's somebody's
paying these guys yeah then you find out
that they're that where were we out
there's a party and there's a hot chick
here I'm like how do you hear she's like
either pay me man like yeah I like I
always feel like I don't want to be that
guy I don't want to be part of that
clique of dudes where they look at me as
a dude the old barnacle with it's just
gross and so that's why I always lie
about my age when I have sex with them
and it's very good it's just a sad see
it's a sadly it's somebody's dog I don't
want to be right I don't want to be
paying I'm not paying for sex you know
this gets gross and I and I mean by not
paying I I don't want to pay you so it
is somebody that's all tries it's very
strange
yeah chin look at that that's court
services that's what I'm guessing the
are right or they're not probably
optional yeah scram girls aren't ya yeah
or they're just whoa what's this now
okay and to be 18 years old so you can
actually these are girls that are
available professional at school yeah
but you think they look like that then
you or them and you get [ __ ] so
monster with a [ __ ] to set your house in
dogs right give me various even can't
they look like that
are you sure Germany I mean this is just
sex trafficking at its finest ladies and
gentleman yes I guess so
right look at how prevalent it is hi I
mean if you're just some dye piece
Instagram girl and some do you know and
you're well I remember yeah I mean the
Instagram chains ranting on a Dayton
oh yeah hook up with this old Jeff Bezos
Instagram all those Instagram girls did
second it literally is 100 show me a lot
of friends show me this dating site and
goes name would go that you liked off
ideas like this girl he was boom price
on it what wow yeah yeah pretty cool and
the athlete pretty cool coming to town
that's pretty cool man
huh what I'm saying getting it paid my
pendant I don't know man
I can't you went to the top you went to
the comedy store yeah I went to the
comedy store for the first time on
Saturday just reminding me cuz look
you're Space Jam t-shirt somebody's that
remind you have a Comedy Store you went
when on Saturday uh who was performing
it was Chris D'Elia
my friend is a big fan this guy named
Chris D'Elia um who got you tickets
Derek did oh you just asked posted yeah
did your friend have fun yeah she was
crying for 50 minutes he's like I show
my veil for crime the girl straight up
crying yeah like he came onstage at my
friend just started like she's like he
was Oprah or some [ __ ] wait yes Chris
Thalia she's yeah because she loves him
she loves Chris D'Elia
it's just weeping basically easier if
free not amazing if he's literally there
every night wouldn't you but bring up
the Beatles when those girls would
scream and cry when the Beatles first
came to United States picture a video
it's video watch watch Dali Oh nuts they
go nuts Chris is like that B that's a no
but I'm just saying like sometimes it
feels like young girls can go like did
they lose their [ __ ] dudes too man but
like look at this but this is going on
now I know with BTS
true I love you Poland please come to
the window so I can just see you
I saw you smoking before I kissed the
limousine you looked at oh but I love
you and I want you but somebody's mom
somebody's grandma right now and now
they're teenage girls outside
complaining that they don't want to mob
you they just want to speak to you what
do you think yeah you the only band I
see even coast this these days is BTS
man when they gonna need a war show it
did they shut everything down there's
major stars there but there go and we
also got BTS and even the who's BTS it's
a Korean band that you know the boys oh
yeah I mean the boy the [ __ ] yeah but
things about John John McCartney right
for the Beatles Paul McCartney he was on
with a Corden you know I did that
karaoke carpool he did he was with him
in Liverpool so his hometown and he
jumps in and Corden was saying he's
never like you're not people like I'll
know they stopped traffic they're gonna
know McCartney and Liverpool literally
when people saw him traffic stop there's
no horns there was nothing he was people
who's trying oh [ __ ] he's and then so
they went to his old house and walked in
there and by the time that came out as
like the street was shut down he's just
such a powerful star know he's it's
interesting cuz Jamie Cort and I guess
he got into music from The Beatles his
grandpa and his dad was okay here's the
best music on earth then they happened
to be from the same place we're from so
he played in Beatles and Paul McCartney
and uh Corden are singing and the corn
starts crying ah yeah cuz he's like if
my grand dad could see me right now
singing with you man
you know that Paul McCartney goes he is
and they starts going ah yeah it's cool
you know he um when I asked every great
band every great band they said who's
the greatest
well unanimously the rolling stone
interview unanimously every band you can
imagine said the Beatles that was there
that was their biggest influence and and
the greatest rock and roll band of all
time if you actually listen to their
their breath of how their music changed
over the 10-year
it's astonishing the White Album and
their style oh you know who else they
inspired Charles Manson thought about
how to sketch
helter skelter he thought was plain to
him that's when he ordered people to
murder and that's when he'd write helter
skelter in human blood because he
thought they were gonna start trying to
race race war yeah little side factory
serial killer fans out this trials also
a splat let's win rock and roll and all
this thing's were subversive and drugs
everyday guys know they thought you
could play Beatles backwards yeah and it
would definitely yeah same thing with a
stairway to heaven they had all this
like if you play it backwards it's a
sign it's just people doing too much
drugs it's all market for there are
always rumors when I was growing up how
many of the beautiful Ringo and Paul
were the only ones left
yeah then I'll see John got murdered
yeah he just got shot it was in New York
yeah just right outside yet shut yeah
but some crazy yeah I am
what the [ __ ] is his name were you in
New York Denby I was does the same year
people work worth like I remember you
know in fact I was I was it was actually
I was in New York but I lived overseas
never happened but I was in there well
so he got killed in the Dakota which is
where Woody Allen lives and a lot of
famous people right now under for
building yeah it's a building that yeah
Dakota is a building an amazing build
really see it oh it's the best build in
what I thought it's on Central Park West
and it's it's it was always the place
where you know Lennon was shot and
killed in December 1980 Harrison died of
lung cancer McCartney and Ringo Starr
remain be sure I was 13 years old you
wanna you know what's in store about
John Lennon gonna hurt some feelings not
a good dude now you dude really yeah
you've seen that no terrible V daddy
with domestic violence and [ __ ]
no oh yeah well Yoko Ono is kind of a
nightmare
I'm sure yeah I'm sure she had help you
knows the girl that broke up the Beatles
they always say you know [ __ ] she was
not even did you ever see a John Lennon
yes she's not hot at did you ever feel
bill burrs commentary on Yoko Ono when
she was on the SS all its to put bring
that up on like what are you doing no
she on Lennon she was such a [ __ ]
she she literally was
such a [ __ ] she-she-she comes from
this industrialist family watch her bill
burr watch Bill burrs commentary on Yoko
Ono hey you never bury Chuck Berry and
and Chuck Berry and [ __ ] John Lennon
are doing a song together and watch her
come in watch this is this one on top
for the wheel Bert funny rent bill burr
you're gonna rain watch this watch this
Yoko Ono makes Julian Lennon by letters
he wrote to his dad at auction he also
wanted a Model T this is one no it's so
funny to do is make some hot one you but
you've never heard of it's the top
record let the the back history of John
Lennon no as much as people talk about
the Beatles and how great their music is
was whatever you want is the same thing
totally and if I want them different
what I think that the greatest band of
all time but I have to be honest with
you John Lennon's got Yoko and his
[ __ ] band one song on television and
they're killing it it's going great
Yoko's playing some stupid drunk and
even though he has no [ __ ] talent
whatsoever she picks up the mic and i
swear to god goes that [ __ ] look it's
crazy man
what's insane he just stops well that's
where he was like what you can see his
face like what the [ __ ]
I would not be sad she sucks sucks she's
still alive yeah I'm a fine one soccer
in the watch watcher in New York and
she'd do these stupid like art openings
and she's just sucks man was she broke
up the Beatles look at her look at her
today my thing is she's not she's not on
this scale one to ten she's not on the
scale [ __ ] is Lennon thank you well you
watch [ __ ] that mango she's always
dressed up like that she was a real
weird
what a [ __ ] she kind of came from and
I don't use that word less you can't
when I know her son her son well [ __ ]
him too son went bad on her her son was
like well she's you know something about
a narcissist and even he was coming bad
on her I remember and I was like oh
Jesus if your own son is called bad on
you publicly you suck gachi so that's
him there yeah that was that that was
their kid though together right yeah
they have two kids right I don't know
well she's in a wheelchair now well
what'd you get everybody dies [ __ ] I
didn't know that that [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] was Lennon thinking it it said to
one of those things we have all had
friends would date somebody but at least
they're like everything me crazy least
er smokin hot crazy really like alright
you know I like get it yeah but you know
he hits you from now on now and again
yeah she steals your money yep
what a suck the chrome off your [ __ ]
dick I know sometimes current died man
they get that tech that voodoo poonanny
is is really cause it's it said that
[ __ ] I almost feel sick at your agency
Punahou nonny nonny
yeah food open and God Buddha punani
know yuh you know man
oh no don't say who know Yoko Ono Yoko
Ono
that's better you gotta see how they
write [ __ ] yeah I can't believe she had
the nerve to get on stage and start
singing like that
you think John Lola is the back was like
I'm filling well the other Beatles hated
her apparently hated her and she she's
the they say she broke the Beatles up I
just got on that time to be a dick you
house no one shot her well she was where
they took out Lennon yeah yeah he wanted
to impress didn't you want to impress
Jodie Foster or something Lennon yeah or
was that some crazy just ran up and shot
Lennon right yeah do you hear uh Pedro
not Pedro my teens but big papi got shot
point-blank yeah to make a republic
better remove lobbies do you see what
happened the guy who shot him I beat the
[ __ ] she what happened him I know who's
seen the video
no oh there's video well down like this
it's just people just like yes
homonym yeah he's a legend right he's
the biggest coin ever out today know why
it happened do they have any Yankees fan
Oh hold on scroll up chin Ortiz shooter
play it you didn't see the video yet I
haven't seen this video no it's how he
shot him he ran up a no scooter or
motorcycle and then ran up to him and
shot in the bottom look at the top of
the screen here that's Ortiz having a
grand old time dr k sipping on some beer
that's finally good time someone walking
up right now shooter BAM
and why did he shoot him they don't know
yet they thought it was a robbery at
first but it's not a robbery looks like
an assassination attempt he just falls
down yeah I wonder why they shot him
they have no idea
not yet now they're gonna find out now
scroll down and this is the public
beating the brakes off all of this one
do you think I really think he's gonna
get away after shooting the basically
the [ __ ] Michael Jordan of the dr
dude they're gonna kill them I want a
Fiat you hate them we just needed money
like sold off you paid him to do it
right yeah somebody paid looks like well
thank God he's gonna be all right
Jesus bracelet I don't like seeing this
though you know even though that's seen
I like seeing any other Gazoo I mean the
Dominican Republic has a very violent
history I've read a book about it what
the [ __ ] was that guy thinking very
violent history what was this guy
thinking he might be emotionally
disturbed or or he just need but is long
wait but who's that that's a different
guy though
no it's the same dude really God you
know I broke my heart do you hear Big
Papi go don't let me die my good man is
I'm a good man Oh God but they said I
removed his column of intestines and his
gallbladder but and he's gonna make a
full recovery
that sucks to have no callin now gotta
take pills I feel much worse right much
worse yeah Point Blank coulda been
paralyzed I was just dead yeah
what's this or they doesn't say he's not
a danger what he's heavily sedated and
won't be intensive care for the next 24
hours
mister it's not it's no good it's no
psycho no it's not you're talking in
effect his quality of life down the road
ah doctor he'll recover quickly just
point blank and they that guy thought
he's just gonna drive off what you think
should happen I get I think this should
beat him to death
I think he's be still alive I want to
find out if he's a hired assassin I want
to find out that Dad was the worst
assassin enrolled he's on a scooter
that's the kind of [ __ ] where I go well
that's like somebody's wife you know you
were [ __ ] around some there's has to
be some backstory him in the dr you know
he's basing he's the face of the nation
of god there and you shoot him
there's the consequences you can't go
anywhere now so yeah who knows so he got
her he got a stash
stooge to do it you know fashion thing
or was you know who knows I don't know I
can't wait to find out
yeah it's something something they have
to find the dominican police will
they'll get they'll get information out
of this young man yeah just want to stay
out of the dr lady see what happened in
american there just died
and then we are psych mmm they had bad
hearts and america's well no i thinkin
work for us
dr cazuela this one was having hard
issues on medication again no no we know
that that's not the reason they died so
we get the talk theology report then
we'll be able to find out take seven
weeks though but the dr goes nah man
they came here on their own they just
died it was nothing we did yeah suspect
somebody got booked I keep my ass here
yeah although my daddy just could happen
my dad just fell asleep at the pool
completely crowded in Mexico while it
taken phone taken yeah right in front of
them it's just on vacation but there are
people that know that and they're gonna
you can't fall asleep at the pool with
all your [ __ ] hanging out I mean white
kids on a Jeff come let's come on Papa
Cleo's who would dare who was could have
been come on pops ever know mmm yeah
wonder what's gonna happen to that guy
I'm gonna find out why he did it I
remember I left a [ __ ] high I left a
camera my father's really expensive
camera back in the day it was like this
all and I left it sitting like in the
back window with the windows rolled down
yo and I got taken my father goes I
don't steal and I would have taken it I
don't steal it
I would have taken it what were you
thinking hello
3:30 2020 I couldn't get the sorry out I
was like so sorry yeah I was like my mom
started driving I was like sorry
go ahead man sorry yeah is there a more
of a house when you lose your wallet
there's nothing worse was your dad
irritable when you would go on vacation
like uh no not really man that's pretty
chill my dad was irritable really I
yeah yeah anything went wrong it was
slip out
yeah I'm gonna drop this it's cool it
was a problem yeah yeah so yeah that's
never was never a warm fuzzy time on
holiday no no he would always threaten
to leave we're going home well you guys
that were you guys baby kids though when
we write were you worried like bad kids
now let's get the [ __ ] out it now we're
good kids I mean you know no I just I
was wanting to go there and hang out
yeah I was a people person I wanted to
meet people you know girls you go on
vacation hey we're in your pub we're in
some resort when you're a kid that's oh
it's all awesome you could be anywhere
oh do you want the hotel yeah you're
just loving her my son now just loves if
we get a whole video of San Diego we go
to anywhere in LA as long as we're in a
hotel together you can like bounce off
the beds and [ __ ] yeah okay my grandpa
never sure you and me and MJ brothers
let's get a room together and let's all
sleep I tried please
I should have do you guys have to leave
beds rooms with free beds is it one huge
bag what time's the show chance just one
show hey it's a lock so we'll be done
around nine ish we have phone I brother
what should we eat your meal afterwards
somewhere good we'd have to book it now
though or maybe there's a restaurant
owner listen this tell us where to go
yeah we need a good place good wine good
food or uh a big wine drinker but our uh
where we stand
should we say no no no that's a terrible
idea
yeah stay at Circus Circus
oh hey for my dad my dad maybe my real
estate at Circus Circus guy that's back
in the day the place was awful I mean
yeah you can get hepatitis just from
sitting on the couch twisted [ __ ]
circus 24/7 man Ike's
yeah I got a Vegas guy the [ __ ] a
scary there also Jake can we update the
[ __ ] head side you know what I resent
this from ESPN seven years ago I was I
was at when I was like 35 I was in Vegas
doing a show and this hot girl so hot I
remember she had a tongue piercing but
she was so hot she goes you were really
great sighs you guys do you want to come
to a swingers party with me hey he said
no I just said no because I was I don't
remember what I was doing I was like
busy and I was like uh and I [ __ ]
always full regret well yeah I don't
know why this ball it was so blatant it
was so direct that was like a plus and I
kind of like yeah it's kind of like
somehow furry oh I just didn't know what
I was getting into I pictured a guy with
coconut oil like on and who shaves his
chest and I I don't know I just like I
don't know that's a legit you know what
I mean like where do we have to go you
know it's that where do it where like if
it's if it's not right around the strip
then I'm gonna drive to some no no no
they do have the best strip clubs yeah
yeah no it's gonna be really hot too not
a club guy though man no my thing not
I'm not either
I just ain't well its kill some career
events already so guess what I take
finasteride all right I take hair pills
cuz losing my hair now a lot of people
come to me I go Brian can I run my
fingers through your hair because well
first of all you're a celebrity and also
your hair
I've been marveling at it and I'm like
no you can't I know it's a shimmering
field of brown grass but it doesn't
belong to you well the secret is I get
my products from hims I don't spend a
fortune on hair pills all right they
also apparently have dong pills all
right don't need them yet but I will and
I promise I'll do it with them because
you don't you don't have to go to the
doctor to get a prescription you
basically take a picture of your hair
I've done this take a picture of your
head and in like I think it took me 10
minutes before I was just off and
running and they send me my pills every
month I don't even know how much they
cost they're not that expensive but
66% of men start losing a hair above the
age of 35 all right and there is no
question that preventing hair loss is
that the finasteride is the way to do it
and I don't want to hear about it
causing sex problems it doesn't I've
been taking it I'm 52 I've been taking
this for 10 years I've never had a
problem at all all right I don't wanna
get into details but believe me I put it
down all right
so bottom line is for hims calm it's a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness for men real doctors
real products is not snake oil okay so
baldness can basically be optional I'm
telling you right now they got licensed
physician physicians and fda-approved
products to treat hair loss all right so
stop stop going to the doctor don't
worry about it they got you they got you
when it comes to sexual wellness skin
care they got you when it comes to your
hair in general so order now you get
started on four hems complete hair kit
for just $5 today right now while
supplies last it's all doctor approved
so go to the website for full details
and safety information I'm telling you
right now you will save hundreds I spend
so much money I'd spend like something
like $300 for a bottle of pills I'm not
kidding I was we're girls are going to
do this well you will not spend that
much chance to go to four hems calm
slash fighter four hems fo are hims
dot-com slash fighter and stop losing
your hair and keep your dong happy and
your partner happy so this past Tuesday
Alabama passed a law that requires all
sex offenders who have assaulted
children under the age of 13 to pay for
chemical castration which then
suppresses their desire to have sex if
they can't pay for it the state will pay
for it under 13 under the age of 13 so
for the child what cha molesters and
great business basically yeah they shoot
you up and your you have your balls
don't work that's that's already like
you're grown grown man that Melissa kid
that's cool Alabama's getting wild right
first the emotion thing now this Alabama
don't give up well they've had this for
a while there there have been certain
states that have had
this this has been a mandatory thing for
child molesters the offenders would be
required to foot the bill for the
procedure who lets him a problem
refusing to undergo this castration
would constitute a violation of parole
but hurts so badly what do they do
I think they shoot the needle damn I
just shoot your dick thing in your in
your balls or something oh no way dude
really
it's Kalka castration that your boy and
then they just don't get hard to do your
balls shut down please don't I think it
kills your testosterone and everything
that's coming and I'm not mad at this
are ya no they remove the gonads whether
reduced literacy search they don't you
can't unlike surgical castration where
the gonads are removed through an
incision in the body mind chemical
castration does not remove the organs
they stay they stay yeah if that [ __ ]
hurt though so you just get shot in the
arm oh that's lame you can't shoot a
testosterone production yeah I'm all
about it though for [ __ ] countless
obviously yeah and also you have to go
to jail for ever I don't think he'd get
better what else you guys good well that
might make him better though right yeah
maybe so there was a video that went
viral online back in 2014 of a man
peeing on a cereal conveyor belt and he
is currently being charged in Tennessee
for basically tampering with consumer
goods so because he is yeah there's a
video of it that we have but he's
getting ten years in prison
ten years and there's a bit of him
peeing on the belt and this thing I
might wear my lucky charms and fruit
loops if you BA Kellogg's this is what
happened back in 2010 affect me team
taste it joke's on you diff they hosted
it's fine yeah well those probably
coming off the toaster
oh hey citizen sure is I there sure
that's a giant black guy with a huge
dick yeah it's
both I can't tell that a wheat loaf is
dick it's got no he's gonna get caught
right why would you film it though you
would have got away with it can you film
it yeah but also okay dude see you
pissed on the fruit loops Congrats
they're still delicious and milk yeah
who cares yeah some people get off on
you think yeah it's like the guy who
came on yogurt samples yeah yeah say
he's handing out a frozen he's for a
hangout a little fling like yeah like it
at Whole Foods or whatever it was I got
Ralph's and he came on it and this woman
people were tasting it and a woman
tastes it when there's come on that just
come on there's come on this and yep
call the cops they did a little test on
it
oh wow they said who is handing it out
you you know cops know right away they
go go got a guy who gets off on watching
people leave these come strangers you
sir come with us lady though oh right
away she went knows you're come she goes
I knew right away it was caught you know
oh my god I knew right away it was semen
yep there you go that guy what do weird
do what some people are on get off on
that they get it there's like a
sociopath thing where they like to watch
you know people they get off on this
weird feeling of like watching why is it
always guys it's always guys these guys
are never guys are subtle girl I gave me
cheese like mm-hmm I run my titty on
that like but yeah right cool guys are
such creeps
they just say anyway sperm girls really
not doing it are they I put my yeah I
girl do anything touched it with my day
no really women really don't [ __ ] with
that stuff I mean I saw a woman take a
[ __ ] in the store before but never yeah
they're never it's never like they're
trying to buy drugs and messed up not
really they were trying to get away with
it but I think the weirdest thing I've
ever seen was a girl trying to throw a
tampon uh somebody else like out of
anger but nothing like this that's
pretty impressive ugh you know girls
that that's impressive
yeah I mean even I did when I think I'm
told a story before when me and my
brother had that mean boss when we
worked at this rental place he said
smoked cigarettes I took the cigarettes
and shoved them in my [ __ ]
so there's chocolate-covered cigarettes
there you go
and then we just put him back and he
smoked the whole bag oh yeah we laughed
so hard every time you smoke from there
and I'm out that's so good but why do we
do that yeah well you know what maybe
I'm wrong because I did stick cigarettes
in my [ __ ] and Chuck covered his
cigarettes and then I my brother's
girlfriend who I didn't like she had lip
gloss ice poured out blue glass filled
the rest of it up with piss and then
when my brother heard start kissing I
call him PB mouth I beat up for that huh
well it's a way of getting back at
people right they spew I spit in your
sandwich and all that stuff it's a
problem the [ __ ] cigarettes though I was
a hero that day yeah I mean I know a guy
who shut up too mad at all [ __ ] they
treated him like [ __ ] of the club he
shot in the head he shot I guess in the
bathroom and then took his [ __ ] and true
[ __ ] off and [ __ ] Yeah right
that's gross I was like that's really
going too far do you love your hands all
right well you know also don't also hey
sometimes you can have a friend who does
something we were like that over there
like you can't somebody's gotta clean
that out don't be that don't be dead got
our soul has clean enough yeah cuz
remember you're not getting any but
you're getting yeah you know classic you
know the guys wearing a minimum wage
whose life sucks anyway you got to
remember that it's like my favorite
thing I'm not alas how I supply Spirit
Airlines and the guy who's taking our
tickets cuz that's okay you think it was
like that [ __ ] that's okay look yeah
that's all I could I can't tell you I
think I was complaining is he had to pay
for our back but that's in there that's
what Spirit Airlines you don't even get
a [ __ ] chair right you know seat belt
forget it straight Airlines man correct
Greyhound of the skies yeah it's like
when people I love
I look daliyah's part of this I see so
many famous people complain about the
airlines on Twitter thanks United
miss my layover see if I fly with you
ever again right okay right now he goes
alright don't give a [ __ ] dude although
I was ready to go
man gave up my first-class seat you know
it's like all right
my bad the Overbrook yeah sorry on the
way here though I got a kick out of I
was from Atlanta stop off and I had to
get to LA and people are coming on and
I'm sitting in you know Coach way back I
had to buy a new ticket because I want
to get back early and all good and and
you get you know I get sometimes people
recognize you and whatever but as a I'm
not saying it like that you [ __ ] just
a second when I'm in the streets of
Minneapolis I get recognized in
Indianapolis the point is if I have a
poster I'll sell more things but so so
as the guys on in the aisle the guy
stops he's got a jujitsu shirt on thick
neck looks like I think and he goes
Bryan Callen fighter and the kid and he
pumps his fist he goes I watch every
episode and his his wife turns guys
you're so spoiled and he goes I'm
sitting next to you and so I figure if I
had this superfan he goes he was I'm
your biggest fan and now that's the last
thing you want to have sitting next to
you but he's got a six year old daughter
next to him and turned out to be a great
guy and turned out to be you know
actually you know he goes I swear to god
I'm not gonna fanboy your buddy he was
sitting next to me and he made a scene
like it right this have to do with their
look and so what the point is that the
last guy you wanted to have sit next to
you sometimes is a dude who's like you
know a complete superfan but ended up
being a great guy and then we ended up
talking playing with his daughter and it
was great yeah but is it's an airline
story okay I was just saying how the
airline's don't care if you complain but
I made you know like I know but I'm
telling another story now or we could I
know I'm just saying it's crazy to me
talked about that yeah yeah I'm just
telling you else recognized you
I'm telling you it's right here I'm just
kidding you days ago all right what else
you guys got so and by the way listen to
every episode good in fact he's listened
everything it was ever since Evan the
beard so I just think that's kind of
cool that he's cool he will associate
out too you know what's weird is I could
dance people like dude you guys should
have Evan beard as a guest Mike that was
five years ago
what are we gonna bring Evan I have
mommy love him yeah I think I tried get
him a job at barstool
Bellator I know what he's doing yeah
he's doing something I texted when he's
in TV is soft then I'm headed from
heaven forever people forget everyone
was gonna produce it leaves that Fox
doing like digital like social media ok
we need someone to [ __ ] push play on
this podcast seems like all right I'll
do it that's how that happened right
it's a while ago man what else we get
damn so the former Florida deputy that
was on site during the parkland shooting
actually got 96 years in prison for
failing to take action he faces
oh he faces yes you won't get that
though right I think he's being made a
scapegoat in some ways because this was
a failure on many levels and also they
don't have they didn't have a policy of
engaging active shooters right so
there's certain police departments that
have a policy of engaging an actor I do
believe the guy was cowardly about it
you know but the thing is you need look
here's the thing about this you need to
be trained for this stuff and this is a
guy who clearly wasn't trained for it so
it's a failure in general by you know
there's needs to be a new policy set in
place get ready for this
well he was he was a police officer
security good he was a deputy at the
time and he was his job was to secure
the school and he says that when he
heard the gunshots he thought it was
coming from outside the school and
that's why he wasn't in the school while
the shooting was happening he made he
put he created a perimeter and then
apparently when other when help came
there was some kind of communication
where everybody was staying outside
because they didn't have orders to go
inside and in some places in like police
departments are told you go in and
engage the shooter
so in where the [ __ ] was it and you
definitely stay outside no stay outside
well kids are getting shot there's a lot
of reasons I guess first securing a
perimeter versus but when you hear shots
inside you're supposed to go inside I
mean it's your job you're you're the guy
that has that kids yeah you're the guy
who's supposed to go now should he face
a hundred
I think he's being made a scapegoat III
think that I think the better answer is
you [ __ ] up you're gonna have to live
with that he's kind of irrelevant in
this what's what's relevant is how do
you put in a policy where this if this
happens again you you can stop it more
effectively and faster have a policy if
you have to engage so you just stand
outside where the shooting was happening
damn yeah I think he got scared he was
alone and and it goes back to the other
gun yeah doesn't yeah but he's not
trained you know he's not trained it's
almost like you're it's almost like this
you've been taking jiu-jitsu class
lessons and then you get into a real
fight with a big guy in a bar and if you
haven't inoculated yourself that stress
some guys get scared you know that this
it's scary you hear gunshot it's like
really loud people screaming and you're
alone you don't know how many people are
in there you know you have a boom you
know I'm saying though and I believe
what I agree it's your job who's trained
for that well so there's a there are a
lot of books written on the idea of you
with the way the seals and the Delta
Force guys are trained is they they get
in it's called being inoculated stress
inoculation so that's why they use like
real full charges they use live ammo
they do all this stuff you know so you
get used to it but it's really hard it's
hard to prepare yourself for the real
thing it really is a guy he's a giant
[ __ ] and did nothing to help the
situation I don't know if she should get
a hundred years and I don't either
because I think at the end of the day
he's also thinking about what he's doing
there he's stationed outside the school
he's probably been on the force a long
time probably shoots his gun once a year
you know so I I have a friend of mine
does mental health counseling for our
first responders the suicide rate is
very high for a lot of these guys
because they come from a lot of times
they come from the war and now they have
a job in law enforcement
they have PTSD and mainly because when
you're a police officer when you're a
fireman you see a lot of [ __ ] and guess
what you don't you don't have anywhere
to go it's still a stigma on getting
help so okay so they have resources
let's say you're a first responder and
you're a cop okay
and they have on the force they have
immense
health professional there okay now
you're not gonna go as a dude you're not
gonna just go there because if your
friends see that you're going to get
counseling there's a stigma to it so
it's a really hard problem it's a big
problem mental health counseling is a
big problem and suicides a very big
problem depression is I think this guy's
deliver with the rest of his life being
a policy so I think that's enough
I don't think prisons gonna help him at
all right I think I agree with you I
think he's already been disgraced I
don't think I don't think ninety six
years in prison solves the problem I
think what solves the problem is hey
there was a lapse here this was stupid
how do you prevent it in the future you
can punish this guy if you want if it
makes you feel better we don't get the
old the old officers and you know thank
you out this thank you enough seanut
thank you
I don't know there's some guys chomping
at the bit for action so there's some do
to run in there 100% do work 100% who
trained for it
you know SWAT guys are trained for this
[ __ ] I know but you have to what SWAT
guys at school you know this [ __ ]
morons went off the in the field for how
long we can't depend is these guys are
there for deterrence they think that if
there's a cop there somebody's not gonna
do it the kid who did this was obviously
mentally deranged he's a he how many
times they go to his house this kid has
a history of mental health he's on the
radar for yeah he's got a history of
mental illness this is a figure I looked
at him was like he's not gonna do right
this is Ben if this was this is a
failure on multiple levels and I think
he's being made a scapegoat by the
political establishment they kind of do
something yeah so let's let it be one
guy in seven sent him away from 96 years
not gonna solve a problem not gonna not
gonna prevent another Jam if I was done
right it just makes everybody feel good
that they're doing something I think
it's [ __ ] with us I would leave the
guy alone
yeah his punishments coming by you know
I mean he's like yeah try getting a job
try beating his kids this group he's an
older guy too I mean look at how old he
is how old is it's called [ __ ] guy
he's certainly not in shape you know
that a lot of these a lot of departments
don't realize if they don't require a
physical 40s
that's another Scot that's a guy to kill
her that's the killer who killed he's a
real sweet guy
you know it's I don't see it
are you gonna choose two teeth at least
II look at how old he is dude he does
look old though illegals an older man
all right what else you guys get so this
past weekend was Pride Week here in LA
and there are three men in Boston who
want to create a straight Pride Parade
and they're facing some backlash but
their pride their statement is that
straight people are now being treated as
second-class citizens and they just want
to have a parade where they can go and
be there straight cells so hard pins in
there it's called The Rose ball you're
also saying that they're not anti-gay
that they just want to bring their
issues to light up you know it sounds
like they're gay right it sounds like
all the Rose Bowl that's [ __ ]
hilarious
shut up like why I know it's been so
hard being a straight white guy
she's just so stupid let the gays have
their parade let the gays have their
parade also you've been afraid they're
super gay there's so gangman and play
everybody's naked it's fantastic but
shut up the hot oh I knew I was gay
pride yesterday here I told my girl said
we ain't going nowhere at a bad feeling
something's gonna happen my lashes they
got that one guy with all those ak-47
santa monica that's right [ __ ] yeah I
don't by the way I don't go to parades I
don't go to these large a man no no I
also well I am but straight dudes like
bro parade Sunday be there I just don't
like that many people are cuz I do feel
like it's a target for some some
shenanigans yeah I agree
how about this I don't know if you're
like this when I come out of my club
I've stand up or I come out of a bar and
hanging out so it was while I was after
my show Saturday night hung with Matt
material and a couple of guys now I
leave early because I got I gotta get up
early I come out it's 1:00 in the
morning
it's Indianapolis there are the streets
are crowded with people drunk and loud
and right and there's just a lot of
pelota a lot of [ __ ] a lot of energy in
the air nothing good happens after 1:00
a.m.
nothing good I'm like I gotta get though
I'm scooting a wedge she doesn't hang
out no sure enough there's a cop car
lights taking his shot nightmare no no
what else yet next story all right you
watch this Brian cuz you know tennis
right I have a seven-year-old haven't
seen this all right so this guy Nicolas
Mott this is the I guess the third round
this one he got eliminated from French
Open and his son was by there seen his
dad his dad was crying so the son runs
over and I'll show you the video see so
he on eliminating I just got eliminated
why the other fan stream cause it's done
right over yeah so psyche comforts in my
son and that's his opponent who just won
against him and check him on a bit
[Applause]
this son jump out of the stands I think
he's on the on that clay filled with
giant bag and check out his opponent
so he's crying too
that's pretty cool I love that yeah I
went viral like really cool g77 million
views so cool you guys already talked
about Justin Bieber
you want to talk about him more
yeah I randomly called out well not that
we know why Cano I'm Cruz out of all
that's okay we don't know yet yeah I
didn't know that huh
Bieber call out you didn't see this be
recall that wants to ask Dana white to
fight him in the Octagon I got my money
on Tom Cruise Tom a lot of people do
wrestler he's not wrestling he wrestled
Tom Cruise high school oh yeah
okay the one he wanted to go to college
wrestling well I don't give I wouldn't
consider him wrestler but I'm just
saying he beat the [ __ ] adjusted me
correct
Scientology crazy there's also a ton
sick much stronger than Justin Bieber
much bigger and stronger yeah I don't
know as much I'll call Tom Cruise thick
either he's thick I've spent time with
him yeah I've seen him very wide oh yeah
he's very powerful I'm not kidding I
just think I don't know about the sheer
numbers I think you'd beat the [ __ ]
gonna be her though
he's crazy does all want to fight the
Octagon Tom if you don't take this fight
you scared you're scared and you smell
your lungs yeah why oh that's a big view
of mine you'll never live down who's
willing to put on but why do we have any
idea that one knows why that's right
that's why the headline says Twitter's
confused his head you know what bums me
out then Connors I can't I'll fight yes
wall bears the same card I was like oh
god I feel sick
I just happening back when Mark Wahlberg
was marking mark I
I'd have still slapped yours off him and
took my UFC shares back alright it's
very weird it's super random alright
people are saying obviously that why be
white like did Tom Cruise do something
to Bieber that's the vein going to hose
it's also at Bieber's age it's where to
call a Tom Cruise's
yeah they said that Bieber is also like
recently taking a hiatus from music to
work on himself and then this happened
he's been famous you go crazy
mm-hm he's choking it's just really
really really terrible joke though if
you're gonna call somebody out you see
Logan Paul's okay let's do it be here if
you want someone young let's do it Oh
God way too big way too strong it's so
stir all that's just yet so strange yeah
but I want to know what Tom Cruise dead
well if Tom Cruise like yeah I [ __ ]
this girl what do only deal Scientology
shut Scientology I I would 100% take Tom
Cruise everyone saying that even odd
shark Tom Cruise is one intense
[ __ ] yeah oh this was this
happened last week this was great this
is so crazy cuz this woman you have to
remember she's there's different reports
but she's 74 75 years old as god this
would have killed me this is not fun and
even look at what the pilot said it it
says sometimes would when we bring
helicopter up from the ground it will
start to spin so we have a line attached
to the basket that's supposed to prevent
that today it didn't today we do have
that yeah how much y'all thank God I'm
safe pull me up boys this was this was
so fun
come on oh no it'll it'll hopefully play
off it was you Jake I would feel so sick
how many times did she not die no no
there's actually thought she was gonna
die from the spin of course she did I
thought I was gonna die god
I mean I counted like something like I
don't know how many times it's not even
just how its size it's how fast you so
it has to be so unsafe they take the
damn video down why don't they take that
down no no I was up here earlier
sure it's all over YouTube though yeah I
mean she's all why so many people
getting lost in the [ __ ] woods these
days it's like the third one this isn't
the better video though oh thank God I'm
safe she's not moving a little bit but
whatever we'll figure it out dude eleven
twelve how are you not dead fifteen
sixteen eighteen oh my god that's not
even the worst of it got worse
and they're gonna fly with her spinning
like that yeah well luckily when they
started flying and starting down a
little bit good thing counts counting
those why did you get 48 so far I mean
[ __ ] that's awful
we're throwing up no thank you
I mean did how did she not die I don't
know
and she's not you know 74 or 75 years
old so her husband updated saying that
her her face and her eyes were all blue
and her toes are all blue definitely
past that by now yeah yeah well the
blood vessels broke oh my god a little
blood vessels is she gonna sue the like
this is just that's insane
do what would they do
why did I guess they know you're a good
take off no she's good just spin around
here and one of the pilots said oh he
there passed out by now they must be
passed out by now I don't know but there
was a spin boat those going super super
crazy it's not good she suffered
injuries right just that just that stuff
Oh like the bruising in the face because
of all the blood popping ah dude that
really sucked I would just leave me and
of course this my way Matt [ __ ] that
that looks like a nightmare yeah oh
what else ya know what's this here Mark
Stevens who's a minority owner owner of
the Golden State Warriors he pushed this
guy Cal Lowry see this no so this Kyle
Lowry who's like the third best player
second best player on the Raptors fell
into the stands and owner he didn't fall
into him he's like to the side of him
pushes him and his Larry's like is it
the owner of the team has a minority one
honey I know he plays for no other yeah
I love the team so he pushed them in
Larry's like the [ __ ] this dude just
pushed me man so they banned him for a
year find him $500,000 you could see it
here but he's a like he's like
billionaire
they pushed him there for no reason
how weird is that and see watch how
watch this crashing English there you
see the reason naming their just does it
to be a [ __ ] it and that's as fast
tonight too [ __ ] those Durant is back
tonight you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] Toronto Bucks trance bad
easy Bret nah man I'm upset and yes the
girl get a bathtub Brandon Brad you're
playing the Warriors
yeah Warriors the Curry's I can't wait
for my warriors yep the boys are back
see what's up [ __ ] though isn't it the
final game tonight no no oh bride
doesn't watch much anyways this guy got
fined $500,000 which isn't [ __ ] for him
and on top of that so he was banned for
a year from any goal to say word games
and then so he might be pushed to sell
his shares he does if he does get pushed
to share him he's gonna make way more
money cuz there was there any what like
did no just the pen so that woman does
that tell me that one one that standing
next to him was his wife but he didn't
hit his wife the wife just moved away ya
know it's got I think he's wanted to
show off like he's protecting their wife
or something um it didn't look that
malicious it looked more like but his
face he was like no yeah yeah but
wouldn't talk [ __ ] is it is it because
the guy was about to fall on him and he
kind of pushed him away that no it
wasn't like oh yeah it's pretty far away
is it one more time I'm gonna make mine
[Music]
so with 19 close fish there you see the
game and the fall was over could Salem
and then Perce ISM he apologized
afterwards but what did LeBron say
there's absolutely no place in the in
our beautiful game for that at all so
many issues here when you sit courtside
you actually know what comes on being on
the floor you don't know it's on the
back deep blah blah be a family part
owner of the war is know exactly what
he's doing
we're something called for you the rules
more than just that rich person okay
some of these we've done ASAP swift
action for his actions just think to
yourself what if Kyle Lowry would have
reacted put his hands on him
you guys would be going crazy okay
because it spread I've been quite
through then at home alright no matter
well he says privilege ain't welcome
here anyways it was that guy's bad he
apologized rants back tonight [ __ ] goes
well see these wins tonight that might
be your favorite player right Durant's
my favor player yeah what was that thing
you saw there was a special on him or
something right I wanna watch that uh
dude there's a special on Ron Artest
right now that Showtime Dave it's so
goddamn good it is what's good I grew up
on the streets of New York and like like
[ __ ] mob deep nas all of them it's
crazy all in the same age grew up in the
same apartment building really sad they
say some wind project yeah like they
said when mob deep blue up he's like the
guys from the seventh floor that's them
he's like yeah and they said Ron Artest
dad no matter what snow whatever you him
his dad playing one-on-one full court
and they go he was the only do we go out
there'd be freezing cold his dad make
him play pale he goes his dad would like
elbow him you know what the rule is or
they're playing the projects no layups
cuz a [ __ ] move so he's girlfriend
layup you get fouled hard so I tested
like size brought death to the NBA he's
like oh he's played just hard Wow
so they would show videos of like guys
scoring like 50 points our test went
like and just [ __ ] the guy up you think
that's just the way I grew up playing
against my dad as a grown man mad or
yeah mentally mentally ill for sure by
but he talks about bipolar he grew up
with horrible anger issues we got to st.
John's because the coach didn't do
something he like
the phone out of the wall and trash the
office like did what what did the friend
when he got in that fight
that did that did that bring him into
the national conscience or was he always
a great he was always a great player
Bobby's right before the fight yeah that
yeah I don't he bit and then he also hit
the game-winning shot Game seven for the
Lakers he went on to great things great
basketball player defense player of the
year that what's in store about that
fight is when everything they were there
destroying the Pistons they were up like
thirty so for him to why he was still in
the game we have no idea and he fouled
that guy pretty hard then Ben Wallace
came charging at him and he's just
started going to therapy and got
diagnosed that he's bipolar and doing
his thing so his therapist goes pull
yourself out from the situation so he
was esto I was doing I I knew I would
have an issue if I stayed in there so I
pulled myself out I went to lay down
this the score table like I'm out man I
don't want any prompts and then some
[ __ ] in the seventh throwed more I
don't know it's [ __ ] those my word right
now the [ __ ] go tried throwing a bit
tells his buddy was a [ __ ] can throw
that beer can and hit him and his
friends like no you can't because I
because I threw it like this underarm i
dint think got hit him it lands right on
his chest so course [ __ ] our test
like dude if you're at Starbucks if
you're at the gas station throws a
[ __ ] bear in your face you're gonna
react not a bad guy was gonna react I
look out and I see the guy laughing so I
want to go [ __ ] get him
here's wherever we're at but if someone
did that to me right now I guess yeah
I've been third bad beat the [ __ ] out of
yes I went there for me yeah yeah though
me to how's it got when you hear his
side like and I get it yeah
though guy who they don't highlight what
you got to see when you watch
documentary watch stephen jackson
climb up a tros and just cold Cox's fan
watching no one's talking about this guy
but you see like Ron Artest like grapple
this guy and you see this [ __ ] seven
footer out of [ __ ] you choose rocks
and fan nobodies no one's talked about
it he got spent for the year I think
Stephen Jackson got like 20 games Wow
there is you see oh yeah you see him
just beating the [ __ ] someone know
talked about him yeah here's but there's
what they tell you in the documentary
that they don't tell you that you don't
see on here they get back to the locker
room and they said Ron Artest was so
like out of his mind so detached that
all the players are pissed that that
happened so they're all in the locker
room they said their coach Larry Brown
who's one of the Hall of Famers starts
crying he said yes gave the sport such a
black guy this is what all of us will be
known for from here on out I've worked
my entire life for this since he's
crying and we're on our test looks up
and they're all like they're drowns up
in Ron Artest goes you think we're get
in trouble for this and Jermaine O'Neal
goes what the [ __ ] you talkin I was do
you think we'd spend for this and then
they start fighting so then it's the
coaches and the paces they start
fighting in the locker room again
because they said Ron Artest was so like
this dumbfound like man II think we're
in trouble and I guess steam jacks goes
pro we probably have jobs from are you
[ __ ] idiot here's where probably
never playing basketball again or even
get in trouble and they said it's just
start fighting Jesus Christ it's
hilarious that is how it's cool to see
because Jermaine O'Neal and Ron Artest
hated each other despised each other I'm
sorry who's Jermaine O'Neal was a was
basketball player one of the greats he
was the captain the Pacers he's really
good but they [ __ ] despise each other
they wouldn't talk to him practice and
[ __ ] that's good man I so check out the
doc though they get into it but Steven
Jackson's the real MVP of that don't
throw [ __ ] it a giant super athlete not
a good idea yeah it's just a [ __ ] don't
what else you got this is a rapper his
name is Yo Gotti and this is a security
so a fan tries to jump on stage and
dance with them and look how fast the
security jumps and grabs this guy or it
actually takes him down and look at his
reaction the rapper's reaction here so
he's just calm the guy gets on stage Hey
oh great and the thing is the rapper
actually sees that that guy's coming at
him he still Bob's his head and he knows
the skirt he's gonna go out he's like
right oh you could see he turns he sees
him right yeah Jay
Christ's [ __ ] blindside [ __ ] tap
Bobby Boucher style bro holy [ __ ] yeah
let's not go ahead and get up on that I
won't think I was thinking just pretty
high telegram
yeah just like hey I'm gonna do hey hey
I got my tank top on I got my dreads I
love I love music - that's hilarious we
don't see yet this is the last one this
is from last week though but not this
one Tracy Morgan and his two million
dollar Bugatti he drove it like half a
block I think it was a mile from
dealership and they got hit yeah and
then he actually got pissed off at that
woman driving and banged on her
windshield
you'd be so frustrating so now the cars
can't affect yeah now what did I did
this him you know it's him banging what
watch
you had he's so frustrated you're Tracy
Morgan where'd she hit it so they're
both trials she's trying to make a right
turn while he's trying to astray me all
over the seat like that though cuz he
can't get out
Oh cuz she hit her right yeah yeah the
[ __ ] is he wearing he's got some money
huh oh yeah from Walmart truck its
undisclosed they think hundred million
well you got a friend I do got a a two
million dollar Bugatti but just like
that
it's it was like you know [ __ ] now what
what you know cars what is what happens
now i me two million so that thing's
investment now you're kind of [ __ ]
because it goes back to the factory and
have to well they gotta fix it I don't
know because I it's it's you know like
any time you run it like when you do the
CARFAX it's gonna save it's been a you
know car wreck
so if even if you fixed it - basically
showroom new it's still in a Colorado
values the car oh look it's not crazy
but well first of all you get so they're
gonna have to is there's no panels on
that thing so then you have to redo the
entire bumper we do it as you did kind
of thing no no no carbon fiber this
carbon fiber so you can't buff out
carbon fiber so you have to replace that
yeah it's not terrible but two million
dollar car so that's probably be a few
maybe 1000 gesture and she's through the
[ __ ] I forget I'm the insurance is
crazy on those things Abu gosh subin's
stupid is that car gets you excited yeah
I I wasn't that crazy about him then I
saw one when I was driving down Brent
when I was a Coley [ __ ] that's a
good-looking car it's it's just so
unattainable it's like yeah I don't know
who makes him Bugatti just a company
named Bugatti I was even that in indem
but then I when you see one a person
like holy [ __ ] that how fast fast super
fast but when you if you're going full
speed the tires only last seven minutes
what you'd have to replace the tires how
fast tires are I think 25 grand there so
it there there so stood the maintenance
typing maintenance on a Bugatti there's
stupid how
every year every year 207 215 turning 25
used to be the fastest car in the world
they say it might be maintenance cost
around 21,000 a year so recommended
every tire change recommend every 2,500
miles and it's $33,000 dollars per set
per set
what does that mean so for us we're all
set a forced 33 grand but just to change
the oil they have to take the whole
engine out change the oil then put it
back in everything's so expensive on it
it's kind of crazy crazy but if you got
if you said 2 million to spend on car
you pan oil chance can ring you up a
staggering $21,000 do you ever tell you
when I when I had that Bentley GTR man
that dope ass Bentley yeah yeah when I
took it into yet oil change it they I
forget they some stupid number go the
[ __ ] for an oil change in the guy goes
dude come on
nobody's Bentley who didn't give us no
one gives a [ __ ] about how much you guys
changed in the whale how's it gone out
of here man yeah see yeah they're cool
they're cool car though man okay I don't
know though that thing's so [ __ ] sick
there show expand just it's just a race
car yeah they're cool though do they are
they represented in Formula One or any
no McLaren is God they are beautiful
though they're cool there's completely
different I've only seen one real one of
my lifetime access shouldn't say that
saw it it dealer but I saw one on the
road only once my life Boyd has like
three of them all right the cool though
get one dude I'm thinking about doing
this in fact that's the car for you
that's the car right there cool that it
dude that's it fun show man yes sir
where'd Vegas is that you're off to a
New York going to New York we got Vegas
then I got Saturday I got Tempe improv
Vegas this Saturday a.m. on 22 we have
50 tickets left in Vegas except Orleans
on our liens or Laurel in Orleans hey
everybody my special complicated apes
starts streaming on Amazon for free
that's cool yeah on Amazon this Thursday
June 13th
check it out complicated apes Amazon dog
yeah
kiss accounts Saturday after that I mean
Calgary Yuk Yuk's here we go again Yuk
Yuk's that is June 20 through 22nd after
that I'm in Brea Brea improv first I
haven't been back there since I think
since we did our first show was the very
first show I've ever done was that's
great Brea improv get you some June 27th
to 29th but next week I'm in Calgary and
then Saturday Vegas with Kalyn get your
tickets at T fat K dot-com set it to ya
bunch of [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh this is the
five kid route good stuff